hello freak [ __ ] so and this is the
second my second disagreement with
Jordan Peterson he thinks that all the
stuff in college campuses that's crazy
is because of post-modernism and he
doesn't understand post-modernism the
what's going on college campuses is
people making all sorts of truth claims
about things like race and gender right
I'm black therefore I will always be
this that the other thing you're white
therefore you are this debt and the
other thing no matter what right
mm-hmm that is actually old modernist
scientific racist thinking that's what
these old racist geneticists eugenicist
thought back in the day
it's amazing again sjw's are actually
really really conservative and
ultimately racist but social justice
warriors folks one button your listeners
must know that's something i don't know
the president in that was a shorthand to
use so post-modernism this is where
jordan peterson makes me want to like
throw chairs when he talks about comes
out of french philosophy in the 1960s
and 70s and 80s
Michele Foucault is the most famous
example of a French post modernist and
he'd they get dumped on all the time but
the central the central argument that
was made by Foucault and post modernists
was that none of these things are
biologically determined that there is no
natural essence to anything that
everything is a social construct which
means that we now are free to choose our
own destiny as individuals right prior
to that prior to the 1960s and 70s it
was the dominant belief that if you were
born a woman you were going to be a wife
and a mother and if you weren't you were
doing something unnatural right if you
were black you could never be the head
of a business or the president right you
could never do math whatever if you were
white you know you should do all those
things right everybody's destiny was
determined at birth
and everyone believed that most people
believe that okay suppose modernist came
along and said guess what you know we
found looking at history we found is
just what I said I just gave you the
whole postmodern argument right there we
looked at history we saw first of all
that all these categories have changed
over time which tells us that they're
just inventions they're just inventions
that get reinvented all the time okay
and second of all they have served the
purposes of ruling elites because they
get to put people in their boxes and
control them more easily right oh those
people over there those are black
therefore they should be our slaves so
it's okay for us to have them as slaves
those women over there we don't want
them you know working for NASA so they
will have a rule against women working
for NASA whatever it is right so
postmodernist said none of this is
biological none of this is inevitable
you are now free to do what you want as
an individual it was a liberating moment
it has become the dominant way of
thinking in academia and I have to say
in my view it is the supreme achievement
of academics ever that's it that's it
but it's huge huge so if you think about
it look what how the world has changed
particularly in that in the United
States since then right
we no longer generally have those ideas
at least we don't operate as such so
black people are allowed mostly into
places they weren't before women are
allowed very much so into places they
weren't allowed before all the whole
world has changed and I think
principally from that idea so the trip
that doesn't mean now the problem is
that the social justice warrior is so
called on campuses have used some of
that language and taking a [ __ ] on it so
the trans movement for instance right
that started from post-modernism that
whole idea right is that you know if you
were born with a penis you're a man and
you should do X Y & Z with your life
right the trans movement needed that
needed post-modernism to make that
intervention and say no that's not true
right you can actually be it
because because woman is an invention is
a social construct what trans much of
the trans movement now is doing which
makes me so sad is that they're saying
that I am biologically essentially
naturally you know in my core a woman no
no one is no one is you can't the whole
point of this movement used to be that
you get to choose your gender or choose
not to be a gender you get to move
around your destiny is not determined
for you what lot of the trans movement
now is doing is a good word reifying
they're making these ideas these
abstractions real again they're making
these claims that are similar to sam
Harris's claims and to old racist claims
and to old sexist claims that if you're
born a particular way biologically this
is who you are right because you've
heard a lot of trans people say this
right I was born a woman that's that's
what they often say mm-hmm
what I'm saying is no one was born
anything but you are losing me in a huge
way life you don't think that women that
some women are born women and some you
don't think you're born a man no what do
you warn Y you men for all sorts of
reasons for all sorts of reasons none of
them being Y delighted nothing none of
them being the X Y chromosomes with them
being you have testicles only one thing
you have a penis none of them being the
fact that you generally gravitate
towards male activities like boxing
kickboxing aggressive thing just went
through this whole thing now you did you
all Romero and Andy Dick yeah but you
know they both meant but you you now
you're a man yeah right we're not
talking about the broad spectrum of
masculine behavior we're talking about
no one is born a man you're not born a
man I'm not born I think I'm saying that
Vic know I think we're getting silly
hold on here I think it's the category
of man becomes meaningless does it yeah
we just did this man no we did and why
we didn't tell Romero and Andy Dick a
broad category Hillary at the ends of
the spectrum and I think they cross over
the male-female lines do cross over when
you get to that Kenyan Runner and in
yeah but that's some plan that's so
broad that it comes to me pretty damn
meaningless well the numbers are
incredibly small at those crossover
marks you're talking about a very very
small percentage of the population
neither Andy Dick nor Yule yellow Romero
are trans people right really might be
they are so different though physically
in every way okay yeah but we both put
them in the silly category called man
what the hell that means anymore Andy
has children he made them impregnated
different women and got babies from a
lot of people called men who don't and
can't can't okay yeah but that's rare
they were rare way but that's pretty
rare not that rare oh it's very rare
yeah most most men when they have sex
with a woman and they put sperm in their
body taking one maybe so that's one
characteristic but hold on a second
you're you're you're making it as if
it's a really common thing when you're
talking about like what a small fraction
of the men can't make babies an
incredibly small fraction so an
incredibly vast majority of males with
the X Y chromosome who have penises are
capable of impregnating a female with an
X X chromosome I mean indeed the male
was born a male the female was born a
female right but what do you mean that
you are born a man or you aren't born a
female right so there are many many
characteristics right that we assigned
to the category of man many of them okay
that's one characteristic okay so why
why is that characteristic in the man
category if in particular that there are
some men who don't share that
characteristic but which ones don't
that's the aberration the aberration is
the one wide elaboration to see these
are going to get a woman pregnant they
don't produce sperm you're talking about
like very very rare cases yeah the same
with for race same thing happens with
sickle-cell anemia
right this is what everybody invokes
when they want to claim that race is
real only black people get sickle-cell
anemia
well guess what the numbers there are
about the same as the number of men who
are infertile
why then are people of sickle-cell
anemia
definitely black why is that definitely
a black thing same thing it's you know
again why are we all these
characteristics why do we draw this
mine called man around all those
different people well why do we do with
animals when you have a male dog and a
female dog isn't there a male dog and a
female dog eventually there's a male dog
and a female intentions now hold on so
before you get but it's not reading the
ancient yeah no it is of course it's not
an invention one of them has a penis and
testicles yeah male thing we see we call
it a penis sure I get it now I get it
and that's the world I live in
absolutely so I operate in this way by
the way so dog penis world you and I
would agree on all the things in the
world that are dogs right and all the
way okay I'm not not going to walk
around be like oh no Jedi our dogs
so with humans you're making a
distinction that there are certain
feelings and the way you interface with
the world that may be more or less
masculine or feminine but it does apply
to dogs my point here which is that we
did draw a line right in those there's a
do all dogs look alike my god there's a
huge variation they're not talking about
race though we're talking about gender
right either way it doesn't matter okay
let's just in credit Dobermans uh-huh
male Dobermans and female Dobermans
right you can't like if you were to buy
a male Doberman and the guy gives you a
female Doberman he goes up but she
identifies it being a male it's just an
invention man this is a male but she's a
male you can't disrespect for by saying
she's not a male you would say that
guy's crazy and you want your money back
are there any two females who were
identical to female what anything I mean
if you have a really good breeder you
can get pretty goddamn close if you're
talking about dog no no there's no there
no two into organisms that are identical
certainly I'm not I turn down to the
hair yeah well technicality but again
don't categorize them as XY X chromosome
zero and I'm not saying we shouldn't
categorize anything ever because we must
do that to live in this world what are
you saying what I am saying is we should
probably stop applying certain
categories to human beings in the ways
we have done like how so because they're
also learn and male and female because
there's certain inventions certain
social constructs that do nothing but
bad things to do no good and they're
only social constructs like race and
gender well tell me how race and
gendered I'm not worried about Dobermans
actually gender definition looks like a
gender definition tell me how it's only
bad
while only the bat-line men as men right
in his women because well if you say
it's it's it's about making the
biological claim the bright the
biological connection there well making
a definition like saying a guy who is
born a guy who gravitates towards male
activities likes females all those
things by saying that that's a man that
this is a born man you're saying no no
one is so if you're saying if those
characteristics are naturally determined
then all all of us guys who don't do
those things are unnatural which things
are those all the tribal things women
whatever it is that you characterize as
being male right that's so common with
males what is being attracted to women
really ageing oh really is women really
us have you heard of gay people yes a
small percentage of the population of
men is it 1% is just 10% yeah what I
mean it's certainly a lot of people
isn't it it's a lot of people when you
think about the 350 million people we
have living in America sure take all the
men let's do this take all the men who
are straight-up homosexual always have
again hold on but you can classify them
as gay men I know hold on so just take
that whatever that is okay just one or
two or five or 10% whatever it is only
been homosexual hundred percent never
been attracted to a loan period okay
okay fine that's still a really
significant significant number I'm not
done hang on then take the men who don't
identify as homosexual have had sex with
women have been attracted to women but
have [ __ ] men hmm prisoners pretty
damn big number they're pretty dense
wait a minute how many guys do you think
that are attracted to but still [ __ ] men
so Kinsey McKinsey study sure I'm
nineteen forties and fifties mm-hmm
found that it was I think 30 percent
what yes
30 % of men [ __ ] men reached orgasm in a
sexual experience with another man yes
30 percent yes yes there's a very large
number and she was hanging out with
freaks yep that's what I think there
were different numbers for women and men
but they were both very significant
percentages very not majorities but very
significant percentages well I have
personally known I've personally known
many men who you would consider straight
who identify as straight who have done
something with men either giving him a
[ __ ] gotten a blow
Valon say allah jerk each other off
Jesus you're weird eyebrows rise this is
news to you
well it's news in that verse even if
they did do that you're talking about
individual sexual acts between people
who are male or female right you're
still talking about a man so talk about
a man that's having sex with other men
you're defining it in that way you're
literally saying Oh a guy you are or no
you are saying you know guys who sucked
other guys dicks a guy has done it to a
guy you're saying a man do it to a man
gotcha I gotcha I gotcha
no I'm saying that people who are
identified as men it is violated I meant
people who are identified as men by
society have done these things that
societal when there were to be unnatural
for men but when they were doing that
weren't they a man doing it to a man and
look what happened to those guys
historically not so much recently but
certain be still today well it's
certainly lowered and we can't keep
going back to 100 plus years now let's
talk about like right now I am still
talking about a man who's having a
sexual exchange with another man like
you can be sexually attracted to another
man it doesn't mean that you're both not
men do you think homosexual men are men
sure why because they're male they have
a penis
they have XY chromosomes they can get a
woman pregnant if they wanted to because
they could donate their sperm
to their lesbian pals and they can all
have them just eliminated one of the
characteristics that you previously
previously said was male no no no no
most men most are attracted to women but
a good percentage of them are gay this
is not like complicated stuff there's
still men yeah I I mean I don't know
where to go from here I mean I think I
mean I think I've made the argument I
it's it's funny because you I thought
you were totally with me for like an
hour and a half and now it's like I feel
like you're not there I don't know he's
not there was a I think there's a giant
spectrum of people but to say that a guy
isn't born a man or a woman isn't born a
woman I think is disingenuous yeah so
it's it's where the so okay Thailand
Thailand I think in India and I think
there's several Polynesian countries
there's several countries where there is
a
legal and cultural and social category
that is neither men nor women nor male
nor female like in Thailand the lady
boys right and those other countries do
have this you can look it up it's a sure
right okay you know about this measure
okay what about that what about those
there's dental - what do you PO I think
there's that too so Oh what I'm saying
people can be born a man but if you
people can be born a woman or you can
get these Andy Dick you owe Romero weird
variation but Jojo take the lady boys
from Thailand okay and move them here to
the country now how will they be
considered what do you mean how will
they be concerns don't have those
categories okay we have only two don't
how to give a lot of variables in
Thailand also that you're dealing with
like really young sex workers there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] that goes on in
Thailand a lot of abuse so is the
[ __ ] category real or not it's
certainly real and trans categorized
real there they consider that real and
here we do not but if a trans liable
really real and I think you agree it's
real and I agree it's real right trans
people I mean there's absolutely people
that feel like they're born the wrong
gender sure yeah so why isn't a man real
why is it a woman
oh they're able to if you want to say
they're all equally real I'm down yeah
I'm dead we're good that's what I'm
saying right it's just that those those
categories have no absolute you know
biological meaning there's not meaning
that they're fluid they're you know
basically arbitrary sorry I mean they're
that we invent them I'm not saying it's
useless I'm not saying we should never
have any categories I'm just saying that
those categories have changed and they
change it but you've kind of been here
you learn the wild is agreeing with you
you kind of did say that a man isn't
born a man and then a woman isn't born
with and for sure a lot of them are for
sure a lot of people that have your
stereotypical classic female
characteristics were born female and for
sure there's a lot of men who have
classic stereotypical male behavior and
patterns and desires they're born men
yes and then there's trans people and
then there's also there's asexual people
this also needs to be considered there's
people that you don't have any desire to
[ __ ] anybody okay they don't want to
they don't
be a man or a woman they can call
themselves queer they can call
themselves whatever they want they don't
want to be a female they don't want to
be a male they just want to be human
here's the deal how about let's make a
deal if you if that's what you have to
say about it and you want to not get in
the way of people doing those things and
making those decisions for themselves
and let them do what they want to do I
am totally with you for sure I don't
want to get away of anybody make it I
don't want to get in the way of furries
that's awesome if you really identify
with being a giant squirrel that's
awesome that's great and that's really
what matters I'm just saying that claims
and I want to end it here that claims
about these essential characteristics
that is biologically determined right
you know are the things that reinforce
getting in the way
laws policies cultures ideas norms that
get in the way of people doing what they
want to do with their own lives hmm
right because yeah I'm for sure with
some people well they mean variables are
so extremely again the spectrum is so
broad so after I was on your show the
first time I got a whole bunch of
comments from people calling me a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and this and
that you can't read those why feminizing
me and it's not your fault for calling
me a girl I can't read those I know I
know it's whatever no I mean people like
came to Twitter and whatever yeah you
don't read though I know I stopped I
learned oh yeah stop I don't do anymore
didn't matter any care this didn't
bother me at all I just thought it was
interesting actually okay so in other
words and a lot of them what they were
really saying and they some of them
elaborated on this was it I was you know
not really men enough right I was less
of a man for whatever reason I don't
know I don't care it's fine I liked it
it's funny but it really proves my point
is that you know these things are very
fluid so they kind of were kicking me
out of the category of man and I was
like cool please I think they were
please insult and rather try to get a
rival and I don't think you can make a
rational argument dealing with internet
trolls no of course not I'm saying it's
just one example of what goes on
generally which is that we do this all
the time right yeah but they're not even
human like when someone interacting with
you like that it's lacking all of the
characteristics of human interaction
you're not there with a person you're
not looking at them if someone's in
front of you like that oh you're a [ __ ]
you look what you'd be like oh my god
I'm a danger it's a crazy person
I might have to defend myself against
this person because if someone is
treating me that way insulting me
looking me in the eye we are so close to
violence like anything can happen here
like this is a person it's not rational
it is amazing isn't it's great
[Applause]
[Music]